back in the original cold war there were
many times the world was on the razor's
edge of world war
iii without the general public ever even
realizing it
january 21 1968 a usb-52 bomber
nicknamed the stratofortress took off
from an air force base in upstate new
york
on board were four hydrogen bombs a
payload 293 times more powerful than the
atomic bomb dropped on hiroshima
this was part of the us's operation
chrome dome an airborne alert program
where the air force would keep as many
as 12 planes loaded with nukes in the
air at a time
that way if the soviets launched a
surprise attack the us would be ready to
strike back
instantly the problem with a strategy
like this is that all it takes is one
malfunction one accidental crash and a
subsequent accidental detonation for the
world to be over in a matter of an hour
or so
that accident happened on january 21st
1968
the b-52 flight started off uneventful
but as it passed over greenland a fire
broke out
the crew radioed the nearby u.s air base
in greenland for permission to land
but after 14 minutes they were forced to
abandon ship six of the crewmen ejected
from the plane and the seventh died
the abandoned bomber drifted through the
skies before slamming into the
ice-covered waters of the north star bay
by the luck of the draw none of the four
hydrogen bombs went off
or at least that's what we thought until
the recovery effort dubbed operation
crested ice reported that the radiation
levels in the area suggested that the
tnt components in the bombs had
actually exploded during the crash how
closely were they actually detonating is
anyone's guess
the us claimed that they recovered parts
from all four nukes but four decades
later the bbc reported that the search
team was only able to locate three of
the nukes
that means that there's still one
missing nuke out there somewhere in the
icy plains of greenland
now you may be wondering if something
like the south china sea leads to world
war 3
how am i supposed to prepare well that's
where today's video sponsor comes in
conflict of nations
a free online world war 3 strategy game
where the objective is simple
choose a country to lead and lead that
country into battle all over the world
at places like the south china sea
with the goal of world domination
becoming the reigning superpower
you get to go to war with up to 128
other players in real time
and just like in real life you can
declare a war on your neighbors if
you're feeling ambitious
or forge alliances with other players if
you're feeling a bit more strategic it's
kind of like chess but with war
my favorite part about the game is that
it's free to play its cross platform so
you can play on mobile and pc with the
same accounts and you can play it in
your browser so you don't have to
install anything
stick to the end to learn about a
special game we're hosting for the first
viewers that click the link below
or pause the video and get 13 000 gold
and one month of premium subscription
for free by clicking the link in the
video description
it's only available for the next 30 days
so start fighting your way to world
domination for free right now
september 26 1983 a russian named
stuntley sloth petrov single-handedly
averted nuclear war
petrov was working at a secret command
center near moscow called shirpurkov 15.
this is where the soviets monitored for
early warning signs of nuclear strikes
from the us
and if an alarm went off his job was to
report it up the chain of command so the
soviets could fire it back before it was
too late
and a few hours into petrol's shift that
alarm went off
the computers warned that five minuteman
intercontinental ballistic missiles had
launched from an
american base and was headed straight
from the soviet union for 15 seconds we
were in a state of shock we needed to
understand what's next he later recalled
after five minutes of electronic maps
and consoles flashing in his face
a phone in one hand an intercom in the
other getting yelled at by his superiors
he recalled that i had a funny feeling
in my gut i didn't want to make a
mistake i made a decision and that was
it
and he reported it as a false alarm and
the fact that i'm talking to you right
now means that he was right
he said his decision was made partially
on a guess it had been drilled into his
head that if the u.s were to attack
that attack would be massive an
onslaught designed to overwhelm soviet
defenses at a single stroke
but the alarm only show five missiles
when people start a war they don't start
away only five missiles
you can do little damage with just five
missiles he later recalled
in the end a nuclear apocalypse was
avoided all because one smart man had a
funny feeling in his guts
2010 north korea launched the heaviest
attack on south korea since the korean
war ended almost 70 years ago
south korea was conducting military
drills near a disputed border where they
fired test shots
the north claimed that the shots were
aimed at them and in response they fired
dozens of shells at a south korean
island
killing two soldiers and wounding many
more putting the south korean military
into crisis status
in the end south korea decided not to
retaliate against a pretty blatant act
of war
and the world makes it through yet
another brush with world war iii
all these temptings would fade and many
more that we didn't have time to cover
happen during cold wars
whether that be the big one between the
us and the soviet union or with the
korean cold war for example
which brings us to today with the
biggest cold war the world has ever seen
where the players are bigger and more
powerful than ever
the us and china in the geographical
center of this new cold war
the south china sea wore this plenty of
room for more mistakes to happen
we continue our look this morning on
what china does not want you to see the
united states says the superpower is
reclaiming land
in the south china sea these are the
terror sky
please go away quickly in order to run
dortmund foreign military aircraft
this is chinese navy you are approaching
our military alert zone leave
immediately
in order to avoid this judgment the
chinese government
has maneuvered hundreds of militia ships
into the disputed waters
effectively blocking access for the
maritime activities
of other nations u.s navy warships have
been dispatched to patrol the area
three times since president biden took
office
us has been committed to the idea
of freedom of the seas and nowhere is
that under greater threat
than in the south
[Music]
immediately tennessee you will fail for
responsibility for all the consequences
for us in the west the south china sea
might sound like just some random body
of water over in asia
what's the big deal well the south china
sea is the china what the mediterranean
sea was to the roman empire
the mediterranean sea was the vital
trade link between europe the middle
east and north africa
whoever controlled it flourished the
south china sea is kind of like the
modern day mediterranean sea it is one
of the most important bodies of water
today
but the main thing being that 30 percent
of the worst shipping trade flows
through the south china sea connecting
the rest of the world to asia
and it has a ton of natural resources 11
billion barrels of oil 190 trillion
cubic feet of natural gas and 10
of the world's fishing needless to say
whoever controls the south china sea
will flourish and dominate asia
and because control over the oceans can
make or break a nation's economy
nations needed to settle on a way to
divide up the world's oceans that's
where the u.n came in
dividing up land with borders is pretty
easy since we live on land so it's
tangible
setting up borders on the ocean however
is a bit more complicated
that's why the un came up with what's
called the exclusive economic zone or
eez in 1982
this meant that every country had the
right to everything within 200 nautical
miles of their shores
all the water within that 200 miles was
their exclusive economic zone or eez
that means they can fish it drill it
control it etc any area that doesn't
fall within the country's eez
is considered international waters and
follows un maritime laws
this is great and now but the problem
comes when you're dealing with an area
like the south china sea where multiple
countries are right next to each other
so their eezs overlap
and since there's a huge economic
incentive to control those waters
all the countries there are fighting for
their piece of the pie but the country
with the most
liberal take on what's theirs is china
china claims that around 90 of the south
china sea is theirs
even though it only borders less than a
quarter of the entire area and in recent
years it has expanded that to include
everything from the waters to the seabed
to the islands inside it to the airspace
this dates back all the way to around
1947. japan lost control of the pacific
after world war ii and china took the
opportunity to take a bunch of old
british sailing maps
and drew 11 vague lines around the south
china sea claiming that it was theirs
that china had a historical claim on
this entire area
later two of those lines were removed
from the map reducing it to nine lines
which would later be known as the
nine-dash line also known as china's
great wall of sand
since china obviously owns all these
waters and other surrounding countries
have no right to them at all this has
led to some creative aggression from
china that's only gotten worse over the
[Music]
years
[Music]
these are the spratly islands a group of
islands at the heart of the south china
sea claimed by both china vietnam the
philippines and malaysia
except they're not really islands in the
sense that you can live off of them
[Music]
zoom in on google maps and you'll see
that most of them are really just tiny
patches of sand and reefs
however if a country can claim that it's
a legitimate island of theirs with
people living on them commerce happening
on them
one would be able to claim that 200 mile
exclusive economic zone around those
islands and basically have complete
control of the entire south china sea
that's why multiple countries have tried
building artificial islands on top of
the spratly islands to be able to claim
the eez surrounding it
with the most aggressive one being you
guessed it china where they've been able
to terraform piles of sand like this
into full-blown military bases with
their own hangars airstrips and more
as for the other islands claimed by the
other nations china wants those
too but if china simply sent in their
military to take them over by force that
would probably lead to world war 3
so they've employed a clever tactic
this is woodson reef claimed by the
philippines in march 2021
287 chinese ships surrounded the whitson
reef for weeks
in an effort to overwhelm the filipinos
choked the island off from resupplies in
transport and to show them who's boss
except again if these were chinese
warships it would clearly be an act of
war
so instead of sending military ships
china sent innocent looking civilian
ships
fishing vessels cargo vessels but under
the engine these ships are heavily
modified with reinforced holes for
ramming
boosted engines making them faster than
90 of the world's fishing boats
and they're operated by undercover
chinese military with weapons on board
this is actually a really genius
strategy occupy the territories you want
to take over by the mere presence of
your civilian vessels
and establish the fact of control and
dominance over the south china sea
through these small
incremental encroachments without ever
firing a bullet
it's kind of like a peaceful protest if
you're in the u.s and you attack these
civilian boats
you automatically look like the bad guy
attacking unarmed civilians
if you're a smaller nation like the
philippines or vietnam you don't know
which ships are undercover
so you're less likely to provoke them
these fishing vessels are cheap
so they'll always outnumber u.s warships
blocking their way and all the while
giving the chinese government plausible
deniability that these ships are part of
their military
the us refers to them as china's
maritime militia a state-organized
developed and controlled force operating
under a direct military chain of command
to conduct chinese state-sponsored
activities and being that nations like
the us use similar tactics with
undercover special forces soldiers
an undercover maritime militia doesn't
seem that far out there watch this video
to learn more
which brings us to today we're going to
warn in south china so i was a sailor
there a naval officer we're going to war
in the south china sea in five to ten
years aren't we there's no doubt about
they're taking the sand bars and making
basically stationary aircraft carriers
and putting missiles in those
they come here to the united states and
in front of our face and you understand
how much important faces say it's an
ancient territorial sea
anticipating war with china the u.s air
force is fanning out across the pacific
for years the u.s air force had most of
its warplanes in just two locations in
the western pacific guam and japan
to counter these two mega bases china
simply built a bunch of missiles aimed
at the two bases
but with that combined with china's
growing presence in the south china sea
the u.s has fanning out its air force
across the pacific in preparation for
war with china
so instead of concentrating the us air
force at just two bases
the u.s is spreading hundreds of
warplanes across potentially dozens of
smaller bases
pushing the world one step closer to
all-out war
it's safe to say that neither sides
really want war if china won a war they
wouldn't go through all these
incremental encroachments in the south
china sea
they would just take it over but that
doesn't mean war would be avoided
as the south china sea becomes more and
more militarized by all sides
just like we saw at the beginning of the
video all it takes is one small slip up
one false alarm one misunderstanding in
the heat of the moment for a small
confrontation to escalate into something
that both sides can't go back
on
[Applause]
shout out to our sponsor conflict of
nations we'll be hosting a special game
for the first viewers to click the link
in the video description
just create a profile type jake train in
the search bar and type jake tran for
the password
spots are limited so don't wait you guys
also get a special gift of 13
000 gold and one month of printing
subscription for free for the next 30
days when you use the link below
support the channel while conquering the
world with the link below
guys most sponsors don't want to be
featured in a china video for obvious
reasons but conflict of nations on the
other hand specifically requested to be
featured
in a china video which i thought was
just hilarious and really awesome
because you guys know
that i like my china videos so if you
want more china videos you should
probably support them by playing for
free with the link below
if you are new here we have plenty of
other china videos that you can check
out probably too many
and plus we have a bunch of other video
essays on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business
so if you like this video you're
probably gonna like the other ones and
we do them for free every single week so
hit that subscribe button below
you can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io for more behind the scenes
day of the life kind of stuff and
memes and all that great stuff
jktrain.io that is going to wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you